battlefield 4 is pleased to present a
side-by-side comparison featuring the
improvements of the netcode patch for
all platforms the test will be performed
on an empty 64 player conquest server on
PC to loan players with stable 50
millisecond things facing each other the
network smoothing factor option on both
sides is set to 0 first out we test
jumping we will count frames from the
first visible frame on the jumper side
to the first visible frame on the
spectator side indicating a jump on
average a 14 frame delay was measured
about 227 millisecond delay between
players let's compare this to the
netcode patch in comparison the delay
has dropped to an average of 8 frames
were approximately 138 milliseconds
about a 60 percent improvement in delay
reduction secondly with as shooting
counting it frames between the first
frame of visible firing to the first
muzzle flash or taking damage on the
other side
the average time for shooting was around
14 frames about 238 millisecond delay
between players let's see how this
compares to the netskope patch
in comparison the delay has dropped to
approximately nine frames or 150
millisecond delay all in all about a
sixty two percent improvement in the
layer duction thank you for watching see
you on the new-and-improved battlefield